Speaker 1: Let's get back to the phones where
many of you are waiting to speak to me, we
do these calls via discord at David Pakman
dot com slash discord, let's go.
We are going to try again.
Our good friend Eric from Cancun.
Eric, welcome.
Let's hope your connection is steady today.
Speaker 3: Hi there.
Gomez has a
Speaker 1: story via Montserrat.
Yes.
Speaker 3: And the thing I'm going to tell
you last week is that, you know, the concept
of Occam's Razor.
Speaker 1: Yes, I do.
Occam's Razor, of course,
Speaker 3: because first of all, in philosophy,
a razor is when you want to get rid of an
unnecessary theory, when you want to explain
something and you don't want complicated explanations.
So British William can go on to explain that
the simplest explanation is the correct one
if it gets better or the same results as the
other complicated ones.
Speaker 1: Yeah, Eric, can I explain it in
a in a slightly different way?
Speaker 3: For example?
Speaker 1: No, no.
But Eric, what I'm saying is, would you allow
me to give my explanation of Occam's Razor?
Is it OK if I take 15 seconds and do that?
OK.
The way I think of Occam's Razor is if we
have two competing explanations for some phenomenon
and both explain the phenomenon equally well,
but one requires fewer assumptions and is
generally simpler, we would tend to favor
the simpler explanation.
That's how I think about Occam's Razor Eric,
if that's OK.
Speaker 3: Yeah, thank you.
Some foreign words and phrases that flaps
his wings and becomes lighter than air.
The simplest explanation for a boat to float
is that it's shaped concrete, the vacuum of
air that makes his float because he's lived
since then.
Why did the explanation for back into the
present is that in 2020, everyone started
to hate Trump because of being awful?
And I think that that concept would balance
out the wackiness of the internet and social
media and A. That concept in my philosophy
class, also from my dad.
And in one episode of The Simpsons, when everyone,
all the adults were drinking the erotic tonic
that homer and they were selling and the kids
were wondering why their parents were keeping
them out of the house while they were doing
the hankie panky, Lisa said that maybe because
they are rebels vampires, they must go home
before dark.
Speaker 1: Wait a second, Eric.
Is that a Simpsons episode?
Or you're saying your dad has an erotic tonic
that he drinks less from?
Speaker 3: The second part is from that Simpsons
episode, my dad also told me about the concept
of Occam's Razor, both in my philosophy class.
Speaker 1: That's beautiful.
Eric, you've really said it all today.
Speaker 3: Mm hmm.
And it's because conspiracy theories want
to feel like James Bond or any other super
spy from the Mobius.
But instead of learning how to hack into computers
and martial arts and looking good with a martini
and a tuxedo, they're making a fool of themselves,
don't you think?
Speaker 1: I agree with you completely.
I agree with you completely.
Eric, remind us how old a guy are you?
I'm I'm 30.
30, OK.
All right, Eric.
Great to hear from you.
I appreciate it's still good.
The weather in Cancun is still beautiful.
As always, I assume
Speaker 3: I'm is a bit crazy right now.
Would you prefer if your weather man or your
guy get more?
Speaker 1: I actually like hearing about the
weather in Cancun.
It really lightens the mood.
Speaker 3: If you want to come have a good
Airbnb place, if you want.
Speaker 1: OK, yeah.
Let me follow up about that.
OK?
Speaker 3: I'll give you an email, thank you.
Bye.
Speaker 1: All right, there is Eric going
to hook me up with an Airbnb
in Cancun?
Love it.